ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
Gamespot Studios I'm your host Chris
Waters here for Diablo I ultimate Evil
Edition Extravaganza I think it's going
to be an extravaganza would you agree
yes does that does that work Johnny
Ebert and Tiffany watt joining me from
blizzard thank you too for coming here
to show off the game of course uh
pleasure man it's it's Tim Med eval time
Johnny you and I uh spoke about this
game at E3 showed it off and today we're
doing like a real EXT an extended Dem Mo
an hour long just going to get into the
game and do a Q&A so we're taking your
questions folks on twitch.tv/ Gamespot
on gamespot.com and also on Twitter and
then we're also giving some stuff away
and talking Diablo I should be fun
sounds great all right so Johnny where
are we starting off here what we got
we're in adventure mode so Adventure
Mode is something we we kind of
developed for people who've completed
the game and we kind of wanted you know
playing the same story sequence over and
over again can get a little repetitive
so we wanted to kind of open the world
up for them and make it much easier for
them to explore the world in ways they
hadn't before so um you know you'll talk
you'll talk to tyal over here and he'll
tell you hey evil is running a muuk in
the world of sanctuary I have as it
always does it tends to yeah you know
not a lot quiet times not a lot of quiet
times um so you'll go over to the portal
here and you'll see these exclamation
points up on the screen those are those
are quests um that you can complete and
bring back to teral so I don't know
should we start with level one sounds
good
yeah now Cathedral level one uh you know
we've completed the game at this point
in the save we've got some pretty high
level characters does level one uh as in
other ways does it correspond to the
difficulty of the quest or because it's
that sort of special Adventure Mode
Quest does it calibrate differently it
calibrates to whatever difficulty you
set so we changed the difficulty in
ultimate Evil Edition from traditional
uh used to be you just had hell
nightmare I'm getting them out of order
but but um you know normal uh nightmare
hell Inferno and then um but they were
kind of flattened and it was kind of it
just wasn't super intuitive so what we
just decided is like hey you can just
pick from one of 10 difficulties um and
well actually the game calibrates to
your level and then if you want to turn
the heat up you um you have a difficulty
slider that can go up 10 difficulty
levels it goes all the way up to to
torment six so if you
really yeah tournament's not enough
there's six of them so uh if you really
want to bring the heat man put
tournament six on um I probably wouldn't
recommend it unless you have some pretty
seriously awesome equipment but
challenge is always there for is that
something you can pull off I mean does
that scale with your party size is that
something you can attempt Solo or are
you going to need a full crew well the
world does scale up um as you add more
um players people remember that from the
the earliest Diablos the the minions of
diaa have G stronger or weaker MH um but
we did want to encourage group play so
if every person you add to the game
you're getting a bit ahead of the
world that you're getting a little bit
of an edge yes yeah and when you when we
talk about like little bit of an edge
I'm picturing you guys have these like
0.008% like you you have it really down
to like a the the calculated margins of
damage dealing and stuff like that all
operating under the hood um I think the
the specific number is uh stuff gets 35%
stronger on console for every play you
out to the game okay so it's not so you
are getting um I'm not a statian but
you're pulling ahead of the game by
pretty significant margin for every
person you add okay so we really amped
up traps in this game if I managed to
hit them I did not but used to be you
Dro one of these chandeliers and it
would do like 5% of their health and
you'd be like why did I even bother but
now actually uh traps will kill anything
any white mob outright and if you
actually get Like A Champion pack or or
a rare under there it probably do like
half to three qus of their damage so
it's a pretty big pay off so is do you
find yourself like angling a little bit
more to try to to try to get those to
hit as opposed to just hitting them
because they're going to look cool and H
it's not going to do much damage anyways
well there's the satisfaction element of
killing a bunch of stuff in one shot but
to make it here let's watch this um to
make it cooler uh you'll notice that um
uh you'll get a a resource regeneration
bonus uh uh so like you know my my
resources a monk is is Spirit so I have
double Spirit regeneration and in life
Johnny and in
life based on how many monsters I kill
by the
Trap and so that's one of the sort of
bumps you made uh for the ultimate Evil
Edition here on console is that
something you're also putting back into
the PC version as well well you know one
of the awesome things about um having
the PC and the console version is we can
kind of run experiments for each other
so we learned a lot of lessons when the
PC team did ultimate Evil Edition you
can't kill me with the traps I know
you'd like to but um but uh there we go
um the uh we learned a lot of lessons
when they when they release um R souls
for the PC sure now we've kind of added
these elements so what we'll do is we'll
say hey does this make sense for PC
we'll do that kind of on a feature by
feature
basis right on all right well you've
been smashing stuff around for a little
bit I think it's time you both sort of
introduced your ingame personas here who
are you playing as what what sort of
skills you leaning into uh well I'm
playing as the
so he's the one with the big shield with
the giant FL he's a character that we
added in Reaper of Souls so he's one of
the new classes ultimate Evil Edition
does include all the content of the
original Diablo I as well as all the
expansion content that we put in Reaper
of Souls so one neat package you can
pick up it has pretty much everything
mhm um and uh if you are a player of you
know if you're a long time diao player
you remember of the Paladin and we like
to think that the Crusader is descended
from the Paladin so he's very similar um
we've obviously improved him over time
but he has some skills that um you know
Paladin fans can can cling on to for
Nostalgia purposes um and they just want
to live that Paladin life again Paladin
life um he's kind of our mid-range Melee
character he's able to cast some spells
he does a lot of damage UPF front in the
faces of the monsters um he has a cool
horse which Johnny just me to the next
Ren um well did we did we complete the
bounty on this level yet I haven't been
paying attention like I cannot play and
talk at the same time so I'm going to do
probably both poorly but I'll do one or
the other even more poor Johnny's been
running in the corners a little bit but
right you got some you got some stuff
killed uh Johnny who is your character
here so I'm playing the monk so if
you're like me and you grew up watching
Kung Fu theater and you just love you
know rattling off a 100 punches in less
than a second this is the character for
you so um monk like I said can just uh
unleash all kinds of crazy damage and
get like right in the middle of the
action uh she's a little more delicate
than the Crusader but she has a lot of
things she can do to mitigate damage and
uh you keep all right well we're going
to dip into some twitch uh and Gamespot
questions here in just a moment but uh
quick note before we go ahead and do
that astute viewers might have noticed
in the top left portion of the screen
there's a little unlocked thing I think
oh no it's not going to show it's in the
gameplay why you showing me anyways it's
there's a little unlock thing in the top
right that is uh because this is a demo
version of the game that we're playing
uh and it allows us to sort of play at a
stretch as opposed to timing out which
is like as opposed to like a pack Prime
when you guys are showing this off you
know it's going to cut off your demo
time is going to come to an end
automatically or something like that
right well just so the next person in
line can have exactly so there's no one
else in line if you notice that thing
it's just there because it's a demo
version but everything else this is how
the console version is going to look we
playing here on a PS4 right we are and
as you can see it's displaying in a
beautiful 1080p yeah we are proud that
this game is running 60 frames per
second both on the PS4 and the Xbox One
and uh while we have it up here you may
notice like that we revamped the
massacre mechanic quite a bit for
console uh kind of what we wanted to do
is what we noticed like on the PC is
people were ignoring the normal monsters
and just racing to the elite packs or
the bosses so uh we made uh we tried to
make uh Massacre a much more uh visceral
exciting experience so once you get a
massacre rolling uh you can actually see
a counter going up which kind of gets
you pretty jazzed but you also notice
there's a XP multiplier that keeps going
up at the bottom as we kill more
monsters that's multiplying everything
we kill in the massacre so right now
it's at 3.25 so we're at 110 monsters so
basically when we're done it's going to
be like killing 330 monsters in terms of
how much experience is granted yeah it
just kicks it up right there gives you
that little
boost and just encourages Massacre
something you guys in the Diablo World
feels so good yeah let's keep that in
the game world but absolutely like toour
absolutely uh all right so dipping into
the twitch.tv/ Gamespot chats of course
uh one of the questions on everyone's
mind is about the patches coming to the
console version how are you guys going
to be handling uh those kind of updates
patch 2.1 a lot of people curious about
what's the what's the plan well anyone
who's who's followed blizzard for a
while knows that we support our games
for a long time I mean um people still
playing you know Diablo II or Starcraft
1 can attest to that
um we do have some really exciting
things to announce on our patch strategy
in the near future and so we'll be
talking about that soon right right now
is it gonna no it's not going to be
right now it's gonna be soon yeah not
today let say that yeah killing me
Johnny all right well cool so there you
go folks if you uh if you stay tuned to
Gamespot of course we're going to have
that news for you just as soon as these
guys uh release it into the wild the
festering woods uh who comes up with
these names is that you Tiffany feels
like fering Woods is something that you
would get down with something I would
get down with I don't know if I like
that
Association we got a curse chest over
here this is one of the new events that
we added in Reaper of Souls so you'll be
able to experience it in ultimate Evil
Edition we kind of pump up the chest
experience wow yeah I'll
say I think we did it Johnny we speaking
of the stuff you guys added for the uh
it's the PC version Reaper of Souls mle
1987 curious to know on Twitch where are
the clickers from The Last of
Us so The Last of Us nffl Rift is a Sony
exclusive so if you do purchase the game
on either the PS3 or the PS4 you will
get access to this exclusive Sony
content um based off the obviously
Famous Last of Us game we decided to
come up with a neam rift that kind of
pays homage to that game um so enough
that game is really awesome yeah it's
really creepy um I think we managed to
pull it off pretty well um neam Rifts
are part of Adventure mode so when
you're playing through the game in
adventure mode you'll just have a chance
to come across the Last of Us neam Rift
you'll notice it because you'll hear the
clickers you'll see the bloaters um we
had a really really good time coming up
with the Nephilim Rift um and so is it
just the enemies in there or you guys
going to get like shabby plaid armor so
you can dress like Joel you know no
you're still going to look like you're
awesome Diablo characters I that's
that's fitting but if you do want to
wear some cool armor uh from Sony
exclusive world we do have a Shadow of
the Colossus set which is kind of a
tribute for a lot of the players who
played that game that'll also be a Sony
exclusive so um you'd be able to go to
the Mystic who is the new crafter in
Reaper of Souls and be able to apply
that translog set to whatever class
you're playing and going to look like
really awesome yeah so what is the new
crafter uh you know what sort of makes
that crafter new what what is it how
does that add to the to the experience
here so obviously a big part of the
Diablo end game is to get the best loot
possible um that's that's the focus
that's what everybody wants and um in
the original Diablo 3 you didn't really
have a lot of control over what kind of
gear you would get you just have to play
through the game and hope that things
dropped and hope that it rolled the
stats that you wanted to roll for your
character um The Mystic kind of puts
that control back into the player's
hands a little bit um she offers you the
opportunity to enchant your gear so you
get to pick a stat that is on your gear
and roll it to something that hopefully
is awesome for your character and so I
it it just opens up a lot of
opportunities to make gear that works
for your build or for your character um
that maybe you weren't able to get to
drop in the world right on um and she
also offers trans mography which Johnny
wish is talking about um and you can
change the look of your gear so if you
really want to look like you're from
Shadow the Colossus you can wear
whatever gear you're wearing now but
still look like you're running around as
I guess whatever character you want
to all right uh we've got people curious
about the giveaways that we'll be doing
here during the stream we're actually
going to be giving them away after the
stream but I'll show you folks one of
the one of I'll show you one of the
things we're giving away here it's uh
one of these pop vinyl guys it's tyal
we're giving away two of these actually
that you guys so generously brought
along we've got tyal and we've got
Diablo check him out
yeah stay tuned to Gamespot on Twitter
follow Gamespot and after the stream
we'll be posting some news about how you
can go about winning that stuff now back
into the Deluge of questions mechat on
Twitch echoing uh some questions you
know that sort of come with any uh
platform you know any game arriving on a
new platform uh can I use my character
from the old platform
on the new platform specifically here PC
to
PS4 not from P not from PC to PS4 but
what we are uh really excited to
announce is that um you can do crossband
Platform transfers um so if I do if I
had a character on that 360 and I
decided to buy a PlayStation 4 I could
transport that character across uh
generations and brand um same goes for
for PS3 to Xbox one so PS3 PS4 Xbox 360
Xbox one you can transfer uh your
characters all between them or is it
just from the the older generation to
the current generation so you can
transfer your if you played Diablo II on
the older older Generations Xbox 360 and
PS3 and um you purchased Al eil Edition
again on the older Generations you can
carry your save forward okay but you
also can carry your save from the older
generations to the newer Generations if
you did happen to upgrade um and as
Johnny was talking about we offer the
cross brand transfers so even if you
ended up picking up a PlayStation 4 when
you were a Xbox Fanboy before you can
definitely carry your safe forward and
keep playing your characters in
sanctuary nice um and if you do end up
purchasing ultimate Evil Edition on the
older generation consoles now and say
for Christmas you get a newer generation
console you can carry your save forward
into the new consoles also very cool uh
I'm really intrigued about the crossband
brand transfer stuff like it wasn't that
many years ago that that stuff on
Console just seemed like there's no way
hey they're going to let that happen no
way Sonia Microsoft but now it seems
like getting along a little better
recognizing that like you know that's
that just increases sort of the value
proposition for their consumers if it
makes it easier for them yeah I think
that you know all the companies are
interested in doing what's best for you
know the community out there we really
want to just support games and um make
it easy for people to enjoy games as
best they can so I I'm really excited
that we were able to offer this for
ultimate y Edition um I mean
we kind of felt the same way I course
like oh this is never going to happen
and then you know lo and behold here we
are and now we're offering these
transfers so they're both great Partners
when we all sat down to talk about it
that was just what everyone's primary
goal was was what's best for the player
mhm all right some questions about the
individual classes big game James wants
to know about any changes to the monk
character sorry specifically let me re
word this exactly monk changes
is that what big game James sounds like
yes well you know it's all caps I using
a little artistic license here but you
guys got anything for me well I think
that's how all cap sounds but um yeah so
basically um we made several um uh monk
changes in uh the reaper Souls Edition
and in some of the subsequent patches so
the console edition with the day one
patch should have all those changes
right
on Mancini 1030 will the touchpad on the
PS4 be utilized oh yes it will so when
we first started playing with it we we
just uh loved the feel of it so you know
you can right click and left click with
it so left click takes me straight to
inventory like this if I right click it
if I right click it it takes me straight
to skills um if you actually have your
thumb resting on the left hand side just
like I did is still register so one
thumb at a time please um and then once
you're inside you can kind of circle
around it uh with your finger we felt we
thought that felt really cool and
natural too and you can click to to
select so yeah you'll get to play with
the touchpad quite a bit and while we're
on the subject of Sony specific sort of
Hardware
capabilities uh let's talk about remote
play on the PlayStation vaita is it
totally work is it totally good it
totally does work and it totally is good
yeah um you'll be able to pick up aita
and Johnny's going somewhere um and play
the game if can you play it like PC
style where you just point you just tap
tap tap tap tap like the mouse clicks on
the touch screen still the same way as
PS4 would work translated to a Vita
there you go that's a good call that's
how Remote Play works right one other
cool PlayStation 4 feature is if you
look at the controller it's got a light
bar on the front MH and um the light bar
color actually coordinates with the
player ring so if you ever are confused
what player you are on the screen oh
blue got a blue player ring and you put
it down you go get a snack you come back
you don't want to change your class you
want be playing as no monk you're a
crusader damn
it vend for you jump back into
bounties all right while you guys pick
another Bounty I'm looking in the Game
Spot comments Mr Hollywood wants to know
uh will there be any Clan or Community
Support in game for the ultimate Evil
Edition um Clan and Community Support is
something we're always looking at so we
might have some really cool things to
share in the near future on that the
near future is going to be an exciting
time for people interested in Diablo I
ultimate Evil
Edition
you guys still festering over here in
the woods uh no we are where we in the
fields of misery yeah all right jar jar
Ms is uh curious to know about the
monster density increase specifically
will the Xbox One also receive that well
one of the things that was awesome about
going to nextg um was that it had just
the raw horsepower to hand
some of the crazier encounters we had so
uh you know for for current gen
sometimes we did have to taper down the
monster density and certain encounters
but we did not have to do that on nextg
and we're really excited about that
excellent and again speaking of next gen
or current gen I guess it is now anyways
we like to go with next gen or still you
still want it to sound like the future
Right Next Gen and last gen makes it
really easy it's very clear yeah uh
jumper jumps wants uh Tiffany you I
think you addressed this earlier but uh
the question of resolution on the Xbox
one uh it mentioned on the PS4 but it's
just tell give them the resolution
breakdown real quick the game will be
available on 1080p on both the
PlayStation 4 and the Xbox One there we
go uh Native 1080 resolution um you'll
need to download the day one patch for
the Xbox One to get that support but it
will be there very happy about that oh
very cool that runs in 60 frames
consistently across the whole game even
if you got four players and hundreds of
monsters on your screen
so
excellent all right so folks again a
reminder if you want to ask some
questions about Diablo I ultimate Evil
Edition go ahead and leave one in the
Gamespot comments or get on over to the
chat at twitch.tv/ Gamespot and uh we're
also giving away some pop vinyl uh
goodies as well as some other stuff I'm
going to show you a little bit later in
the show and you're going to have to go
ahead and follow Gamespot on Twitter
after the show's over we're going to put
some information on how you can win
those there on
Twitter what are you guys looking for
scavengers oh there's the
arrow right on
Q you found it you're within Scavenging
distance oh man we're getting into some
into some deep uh technical questions
here AR tus in the in the games spot
comments wanting to know how the stat
ranges command works in the compare
items screen well I can actually feel
that one um yeah you got me really
scared there when you're talking about
super technical well I mean you know Rel
me reading it I my technical assessment
is probably a little differently
calibrated than yours well we uh the
minute we saw that you could do stat
ranges on PC we we decided we we had to
have that on uh on on the ultimate Evil
Edition so um basically if you do left
on the dpad you can actually see the
stat ranges there you go boom you're
welome see just how well your item
rolled um and you can also see this
while I was talking about the Mystic
earlier when you are enchanting your
items you can see how well each of those
enchant roles goes how they worked out
for you yeah how lucky you were yeah I
was expecting something like how did you
map the memory to this modle exp oh
you're going to need a programmer for
that one
yeah yeah so uh well speaking of you
guys you guys are not programmers but
you uh can you tell folks a little bit
about what you do on at on at blizzard
on Diablo I ultimate Evil Edition why
was the design lead on the console so
basically I helped uh design the feature
set that you see here on Ultimate EV
Edition and when we sat down to do that
our main goal was like we just really
wanted to leverage uh the social systems
uh that NextGen was offering
so you'll notice a lot of our features
kind of center around that you know like
the player gifts that now drop for your
friends that will roll legendary items
targeted towards their characters or The
Apprentice mode meaning like no matter
how large your level difference is the
lower level players are kind of amped up
so they can contribute well in your game
or the Nemesis system um which uh means
like once in a while if I die to a
normal monster it can turn into this uh
super Fierce monster known as a nemesis
that'll actually hunt down uh my friends
in their games and if they don't kill
the Nemesis it'll jump to one of their
friends and uh kind of creates this cool
moment all of you can share even if
you're not playing together at the exact
same time when you say cool moment you
basically mean like the vengeful memory
of your friend getting totally owned
coming after you trying to kill you yeah
that sounds kind of fun it gives you the
opportunity to kind of rib them a little
bit for dying to a monster assuming you
don't die assuming you don't die to it
as well too I need if you die to it you
just never say anything right it might
it might jump back into their game then
they'll know to be quiet in that
situation it might go back uh and this
kind of stuff that uh the Nemesis system
stuff that just
propagates within sort of like if you're
on Playstation will that just be within
your PlayStation friends list that won't
be cross brand yeah
okay hallucinates uh through the
Gamespot comments wants to know can we
get an update or any info on progress
being made to Implement PVP please uh by
the way bonus points for being the first
person to use the word
please well um PVP is something we're
always looking at uh we're not going to
add a PVP system just to add a PVP
system has to be something that makes
sense for the game adds to the game
works well within the current rules of
the game so yeah we're still looking at
that one pretty
closely right on feel like I say right
on a
lot nature of a Q&A do worse for catch
phrase
right I will try not to do worse that
is all right what now you guys seem to
be handling this pretty well uh
obviously you don't want to be dying
horribly during a demo while you're
while I'm bombarding you with questions
uh but you know you me you mentioned
before sort of the range of difficulty
levels available what do you guys you
know do you find that on on Con people
tend to play tend to go to the upper
bounds of difficulty or tend to stay a
little bit more in the you know less
less punishing Realms do you have any
sort of perspective on the way console
players attack Diablo I um I really
think that the console Community attacks
it the same way the Comm the PC
Community does there will be your casual
players that choose to kind of just want
to roll face through the content um and
you know Diablo allows you to do that
but for those that are particularly
punishing um there definitely people
that really push their characters I
think to their limits and really amp up
the difficulty and try to get to that
end game and beat it on the most
difficult difficulty they can um we
obviously have our hard code hardcore
mode sorry uh where you have one life
and I think that is a really big draw
for a lot of players I think get a lot
of cred if you say you beat Diablo in
the hardest difficulty yeah in hardcore
so I know it's a really really big
Community for that there's a lot of
people that stream it um that's I I know
it's something that I don't really do uh
I really want to yeah I stay away from
the hardcore mode yeah that's sounds
pretty agonizing and then more than one
of my Gamespot co-workers here has uh
come in some morning after being up far
too late a lot of people have lost their
characters to cats on the keyboard power
outages cats cats is probably the
biggest one listen environmental hazards
you know they're a thing in Diablo
they're a thing in life oh
legendary all right uh gosh I just had
one and it totally escaped
me I think it was about hardcore car oh
it's about streaming uh cuz you know
there's built-in streaming apps for the
for the the PS4 the Xbox one uh has you
know sort of accommodating those uh
factored into the development at all or
is that sort of not even on your end um
you guys we definitely consider I mean
that stuff is what so Microsoft done is
they've built it in so it's really a
seamless experience for develop to
support it um it's really I I'm looking
forward to see seeing how much the
streaming Community takes on ultimate
Evil Edition I know it's a really really
big thing for PC players um I'm curious
to see if it'll be equally as successful
or even more so on the console because
it is built into the consoles themselves
MH um so we didn't have to do any
special considerations during
development um which just kind of
curious you'll be watching eagerly to
see how how well catches on see the
hardcore streamers defeating male and
tourament
6 okay in the twitch chat of course uh
one of the Hot Topics has been uh that
of modded gear and so that's something
there folks are hoping you guys will
address a little bit in terms of how
that's going to factor into uh ultimate
Evil Edition on Console so yeah totally
so we did a few random samplings of of
high level characters just to see how
tough the gear was and that's when we
got a kind of a taste of like there's
some people out there taking some
liberties with the game roles so um you
know and that's cool if that's how they
want to play but also just in interest
of public games we we kind of wanted to
get that under control so we've added
some new rules that have kind of uh made
it so um it's more difficult for for
players to cheat and if they do cheat
they kind of have to cheat far more
within the natural grounds of the
game put like some bigger cheat walls
around sort of we can't tell you the
secrets of our cheat walls okay yeah no
I'm not I'm not any kind of mole here
I'm not trying to get you uh well we
can't make it cheat proof because you
can play offline you know it's it's all
all the rules are on your console so we
just can't control it like we can a PC
but we've made it so if you are going to
cheat you're going to have limits to how
much you can you can do it offline you
gu you can have a little cheat party get
your friends over sit on your cheat
couch play your cheat games eat your
cheat snacks you knowt the whole cheat
lifestyle yeah we support that
yeah all right uh some more questions
here noodle legs this one from a little
bit ago in the chat noodle eggs
wondering about the insane amount of
damage dealt by fire chains is that
something that you guys have sort of uh
tweaked or addressed in any way well
actually we like that it does a lot of
damage uh you know same with like the
Arcane beam we really like things that
are very dangerous that are that are
like high intensity spikes that also
especially add gameplay by making you
kind of like pay very close attention to
your positioning yeah positioning of
your teammates so uh yeah we kind of
like where it's at right now
and speaking of where are you at right
now did you guys just went into a
Nephilim Rift we just jumped into a rift
um after we completed the bounties we
got some Rift fragments so we went over
to the Obelisk and orc opened this Rift
for us how many fragments did that cost
someone was curious about
that depend on the this is the demo so
right now it cost this five fragments
which is how it was when reversals
launched on PC okay um maybe there'll be
different costs maybe in the near future
you'll find out that it might be
different
all right just maybe just maybe perhaps
it's a
possibility all right so what are you
guys hoping to get out of this Rift I
mean sweet loot sweet loot naturally
cool Rift boss is also
cool and would sorry to go back to the
last of us thing is is it within a
Nephilim Rift that you would encounter
The Last of Us uh demons would they be
alongside other Diablo creatures or
would it just be a
purely uh you know Slickers and Boomers
Rift sort of sealed within its own world
I believe it's a pure Rift I haven't
played it in a few months um but last
time I played it it was a pure RI really
creepy going back to that did you have
some flashbacks the clicker sound is
just I something very iconic and creepy
about it yep he really calibrated that
really
well Saab knot from the twitch chat
wondering how linking to battl net will
work work and what kind of benefits
they'll there will be for doing so so if
you do want to take advantage of the
Cross brand transfers so that would be
from a Microsoft console to a Sony
system or uh vice versa you will need to
link your balet account to both your
Xbox Live account and your Sony
Entertainment Network account and in
doing so you will actually get a
legendary item in game it's called the
Signet ring of the blizzard um it's a I
believe it's a level 11 item but you can
wear it at level one so it kind of gives
giv your early characters a little bit
of a boost um so there's a pretty cool
thing that we give you um and in linking
your accounts it just helps basically
the stage transfer take place um even
players that are not doing the cross
brand transfer can link their accounts
so you don't have to link both if you're
just a Microsoft player you only have an
Xbox Live account then you just have to
either use an existing balet account or
create one it is free on our website and
uh link from
there pretty awesome nice to done
answered I mean you answer that question
really well also the the linking is
probably well done too we like we try to
we try to make it as seamless as
possible and one of the great things
about signing up for a free battl man
account is you could also download our
new free to play game Hearthstone which
I think a lot of us are spending way too
much time on oh man you want to talk
about some Hearthstone we got some folks
in the back who' love to come out here
and talk to you about that for the next
one seriously I was just this past
weekend I was way at a bachelor party on
the beach and a one of the dudes had
brought his laptop so he could get his
dailies in that's you got to earn that
gold it's important it didn't go well
for him
unfortunately the beach party or his
dailies cuz the dailies the beach party
was fantastic yeah but his Arena his
Arena did not did not work out sorry
wrestler calling you out on the stream
yeah he's definitely not watching he
works a job where he can't do that kind
of stuff
all right what else we got here in the
gam spot questions will we have greater
Rifts and seasons on consoles and also
for the go oh my goodness that
degenerated into an unreadable sentence
uh did you make any sense of that
question the first half yeah totally so
um yes we will be having greater risks
on Console uh Seasons no uh just did not
make sense to have seasons when we
couldn't guarantee the security of the
game like we can on PC mhm so that's
going to be a PC exclusive feature but
however you will be able to get to go to
town on greater risk which is freaking
awesome freaking awesome that's that's a
technical term you guys use within
blizzard yeah that's the PG rated
version of it yeah totally um but yeah
you got your you got your goals your
metrics you got to hit freaking awesome
on a number of them yes all of
them all right ry's been working this
question for a little while so I got to
ask it will all of our unlocked Banner
items like sigils also transfer over
with the data transfer they will all of
your uh when you transfer your data over
it will bring over all your characters
all your inventory your stash um your
sigils your banners M pretty much
everything not your hacked items but
that's
good not your hacked items you will have
a brand new set of achievements and
trophies to earn in ultim Edition though
which we think is pretty exciting for
all those who really care about the game
their gamer Point score and definitely
plenty more to mine out I know I'm
excited about it you get the game on all
four platforms that's four times the
achievements and trophies do you guys
have like little internal trophy
achievement battles with blizzard games
are there like you know performance
targets you have to
set you don't have at least a 200 gamer
score on you know one of these or five
trophies what you games have a lot of
achievements
uh some curiosity about gifting uh which
is a feature that you guys have had in
some in some incarnations but sort of
what's the item gifting between friends
policies coming here on consoles okay so
we implemented a player Mail system uh
so you can mail like items or you can
mail like gold or Gems or crafting
materials to your friends which is
really cool however when we implemented
this what we a lot of us start to
realize is like I got a lot of friends
who play Diablo and I have no freaking
clue what class they're playing or what
level they are are so I'm not sure which
items are good for them so we kind of
wanted to make it really easy for you to
kind of share your adventures with your
friends and feel like you're playing in
the same world and thinking of each
other so we came up with the idea of
player Gifts of like hey anytime you get
a legendary there's a chance like this
box will pop out of it when you pick it
up you'll have like your friend's name
on it and it's basically you can send
them the box and they open it and it'll
roll a legendary for whichever character
they open it with so if they have like
10 characters they can choose which
character they want the legend for so
it's it's a really easy way to stay
connected with your friends while you're
playing if you can't get together um and
find the time to play uh together and
Co-op like a pretty nice way to handle
it plus you guys get to design little
present boxes right presumably there's
like ribbons on the whole the whole
thing well getting just the right color
of ribbon you know was actually a
discussion that we had yeah it it
changed quite a few times really there
are multiple iterations I guess we'll
look forward to the ultimate Evil art
book see uh all the different
ribbons o left
CI help me with this treasure Goblin
down here that is pretty awesome guys
are destroying imagine the Sinister
teddy bears really sucks all right yeah
there were some people uh claiming that
they had some significantly better
characters and than what we're seeing on
screen but you know oh that's a pretty
easy claim to make aren teer pimped out
but yeah they're pretty pimped out oh
the unicorns the Carnage but I having
gone through like a few hundred uh
player characters we downloaded randomly
I do have to admit console players have
very impressive sets of equipment yeah
yeah
yeah oh my goodness Teddy bearen such
teddy bear
Carnage vengeful Massacre of teddy bears
keep it going get the unicorns in
there all right just a remind REM ER
folks go ahead and ask any question you
like in the twitch chat but remember
some of them may have been asked already
during the stream hopefully the folks in
the chat have been pretty good about
reiterating any questions we've already
addressed and of course this stream is
going to be archived and live on
Gamespot just after it concludes so you
can go back and catch any answers you
missed also uh we're going to show off
some of the more some of the other stuff
we're giving away here we've got some
lanyards these things have like a sick
Reaper of Souls sickle on them can you
see those probably need to hold them
near my face so they're not out of focus
I don't know if these are TSA approved
to go through uh but they look pretty
great we'll be giving those away H all
you got to do is follow Gamespot on
Twitter and keep an eye out for the
instructions that'll be posted after the
stream on how to go ahead and win one of
those are you still
slaughtering unicorns no we past that
okay all right that's that seems nice
you know we destroyed all the evil
unicorns a phase I cry for help just a
pH yeah that's
right all right so the way these Q&A
sessions go the sort of like questions
gain uh you know momentum in the chat
and people start typing phrases over and
over again legendary gems is the one
that I'm seeing a lot people are curious
about legendary gem near future we can
talk about that talk about things like
that near future are there are there any
blizzard events coming up in the near
future perhaps there are always blizzard
events in the near future well there's a
there's a BlizzCon coming up which I'm
sure most of you guys know about so
we're looking forward to seeing
everybody there
definitely which I just have to say like
that is literally the happiest time of
the year even more than Christmas for me
cuz like when you just see the blizzard
fans walk around BlizzCon and just how
happy and excited they are about our
games mhm just yeah that's why we put
the long hours in do blizzard employees
all get to go to BlizzCon I mean is it
sort of like we do companywide mandate
you got really you don't need to be
mandated just
a get to hang out with the
fans the cosplay alone I mean hold yeah
it's incredible
yeah do you ever uh get jealous that you
don't get to dress up oh we all dress
like that ask people to like try try
their cosplay on it's our normal War
clothing yeah that's that's what we wear
like yeah just another day get us in the
zone you know I cosplay a skeleton every
day at work Tiffany can talk about her
outfit if she
wants yeah
g my G
outfit all
right legendary gems near future people
pay attention near fure all right cool
so let's
see skull
mana
mana skullman Iowa there it is Skull Man
Iowa takes takes a few tries sometimes
to figure out where the word SE Mana
maybe you were right the
first wondering about the bounties so
we've been you guys have shown off a
bunch of bounties uh so far is that
something that sort of once you get into
the adventure mode you can just they
just keep coming you can keep on taking
them on yeah so Adventure Mode unlocks
once once you've beaten Mal on any of
your characters um so similar to Reaper
of Souls on the PC uh you could beat
malale eventually unlock and you can
play Adventure mode to your heart's
content I know I leveled my Crusader
fully in adventure mode on PC and that's
something that you can do on Console as
well mhm um and the bounties keep
changing uh you can go from act to act
completing bounties get your blood
shards you know you can purchase items
at kadala um and then in between you can
jump in these neom riffs uh which we
think are pretty cool because it mixes
monsters from all over the game with
different environments um and it really
adds a lot of
varied gameplay it it keeps it really
interesting and exciting like we just
jumped into that Rift with the
whimsyshire um characters and if you've
never been there it's kind of your
opportunity to go beat up on some
uniforms which I think is pretty cool
also like when I went through story mode
I was just so into the story and the
progress elements I wouldn't explore all
the little sub Dungeons and side
dungeons so this kind of uh tells you
like hey you're going to get a really
cool reward if you do so it gave me all
the encouragement to kind of see those
parts of sanctuary I hadn't felt I had
time to visit
take a little bit more
exploration a little bit more of
roundabout
path sounds all very uh very soothing
but then you get assaulted by a huge
amount of demons and or ponies or Ponies
as the case may be demon P demon
ponies all right checking out the
twitch.tv/ Gamespot chat here for some
questions as well as the Gamespot
comments folks so go ahead and put them
in there be sure to put a little QE
before your UH question if you type it
into the twitch chat that makes it
easier for me to spot or question the
whole word the mods in there will help
you guys
out to
difficulty oh you want to get a little
tougher here it's too boring for
Johnny
all right well we let's talk a get a
little bit broad on ultimate Evil
Edition here on Console cuz we're you
guys are playing Co-op you're playing on
the couch you're playing uh in adventure
mode there's also story mode and online
as well just give us a rundown real
quick um so what we think is really
really unique about ultimate Evil
Edition is the fact that we can sit on a
couch and all hang out and play so our
game supports single system Co-op up to
four players um well I guess multiplayer
just out to four players you could have
two friends at their house playing and
then over either PSN or Xbox Live you
can join up with them um we think it's
really awesome just to be able to come
home kick up your feet sit down in front
of your TV and just play the game in
1080P um and then we do have all of the
content that Diablo I has so far uh
which we think is really really cool and
so you've got all the Diablo I stuff but
yeah then CL just clarify for folks the
difference between UL medieval Edition
and Diablo I in terms of the content
delivery so ultimate Evil Edition
includes also Act five um it has the new
character or the hero classic Crusader
which you can see that I'm playing right
here um and also has Adventure Mode
which me and Johnny have been going
through um and it also includes the
Mystic that we talked about earlier that
has the transmog options as well as
enchanting
um we've got some console specific
features as well that Johnny can kind of
run through so uh like I kind of ran
through it before but uh just um we kind
of two things we we did like first we
kind of wanted to improve the momentto
moment gameplay so there's a few quality
of life fixes and there was a a a suite
of uh features we called action combat
so some of the quality of life
improvements are um when we're playing
couch cop like if you look here like uh
you know say like Tiffany's playing the
Crusader and I happen to be playing a
Demon Hunter because she's a melee class
she's always just going to be right in
the middle of the loot and just human
nature is just gonna Hoover it all up
but half of it going to be mine well
classic Mee dude right and uh so so you
know half of it's mine we have to stop
and she has to go through here and start
dropping stuff manually then I have to
pick it up and instead of using these
quick equip menus we're having to bring
the game to Hal so now what we've done
is we've we've earmarked all the loot in
the game so you see here like it'll say
like P2 P2 uh um these are things we
dropped so once they're dropped they're
free arange for anybody the drop for a
particular player will be to your mark
So no matter who picks it up it goes to
their inventory so you see even though I
picked it up because it's for Tiffany it
went to Tiffany so that means Tiffany
can keep using her quick equip menu
instead of having to bring the game to a
halt so it keeps couch co-op in the flow
and in the mode um the other thing was
um improving momentto moment combat you
know like making the normal monsters way
more rewarding so you know there was the
the the improved Massacre you've been
seeing this whole time get which gives a
massive XP bonuses um it also is what
sparks the the Nephilim Glory gloves
every time you hit a massacre level
there's like 10 levels in a massacre all
the way up to to 300 monsters
um is the highest level of Massacre so
each level you hit within a massacre
drops an neam Glory Globe gives you the
massive XP bonus and it's just pretty
freaking satisfying to to round up a big
bunch of monsters and get that how many
times have you hit that 300 do you do it
pretty regularly no it's pretty hard
it's pretty tough um there's one dungeon
in particular not going to give it away
I'll let you explore but there's one in
dungeon in particular that makes it a
little easier but still pretty tough MH
um and uh let's see uh traps we improve
traps so they give a resource bonus so
kind of looking for opportunities to
kill things with the environment is now
very engaging and then the final thing
is destruction you know rolling through
pots has always been and barrels has
always been cool but now you can get a
little speed bonus when you do it um uh
like a significant speed bonus for up to
60 seconds um and then the other set of
features boy this answer just won't end
will it but um no you got it the other
set of features is um the social
features we talked about player gifts um
Nemesis mode and most important I think
of all is Apprentice mode meaning
if I'm level one and Tiffany's level 70
um I can still join her game my stance
my stats will temporarily be amped so I
do really good damage I can take a lot
of punishment um and more importantly
because we have the earmarked loot now I
can still get loot for my level she can
get loot for her level uh no sorting and
everybody's just having a great time and
you can have a good sort of balanced
experience even if you have played for
80 hours and someone just came over your
house and has never played before
exactly yeah nice very considerate of
you all right let's burn through a few
more questions here we got about 10
minutes left in the Stream uh vision
black dog is wondering are there any
Xbox themed Rifts like The Last of Us
Rifts for PlayStation it's a great idea
we'll have to look into that one but
yeah for now we have the X uh the Sony
ones we're really excited about mhm and
that's is that something you have to
download separately or is that just
included in the uh the Sony in the in a
Playstation 3 or PlayStation 4 copy of
ultimate Evil Edition so you will need
to download the day one patch that we'll
have the day one patch yeah right
on uh red Quil wondering is there any uh
will you be able to zoom the camera out
similar to the view from the PC version
are you able to sort of change that view
or is it pretty much controlled uh by
the game no I mean the camera is where
it's at for very good reasons we we
spent a long time playing with the right
camera distance to work with Direct
Control and this is what works really
best and also like like sometimes like
on PC I'll hit the wrong button on my
keyboard I'll move my camera I'm in the
middle of the action I'm really angry
I'm like I just want my normal camera
back just see what's going on yeah we
just wanted to make it uh as seamless as
possible and keep players focused on the
action not yet B Jack wondering will
there be an ultimate Evil Edition for PC
as well it's already pretty ultimately
evil I it's PR yeah totally but we might
we are going to look at some the console
exclusive features kind of on a case-by
Case basis and see hey does this make
sense for PC if it does there's a really
good chance you'll see it on PC mhm uh
jws player is curious about uh sort of
that couch Co-op if you know if you want
to bring your character over to your
friend's house to play it is there a way
to do that you put on a USB stick do you
connect to your online account how does
that work so depending on where you
store your save um you can either do it
on memory swords like a USB stick or or
you can do cloud storage which both Xbox
and Playstation support you can either
just pull down load your profile um load
your account on the console at your
friend's house and pull it down or just
plug in your USB stick and it should
work
seamlessly that's kind of a theme for
you guys with this is a theme seamless
gameplay seamless
experience well it's kind of the like
you said we just wanted like our our
Mantra uh when we started the console
edition was pick up and slay
so um we're always just looking for ways
to like uh anything that takes you out
of the action anything that that's
keeping you too long in the menus or or
just disrupting your flow we're just
hammering that aggressively and trying
to make it as smooth as
possible I really like the image of you
guys hammering things out of the game
aggressively and then just like just P
I'm just picturing you over some sort of
glowing Forge like it must be seamless
clang like that menu must go clang a lot
of us have those doomhammer replicas on
our death so yeah that's pretty much
what they're the truth
yeah all right uh let's
see what have we got here any uh GL too
many something sky glcl sky any chance
you can ask about gold costs on Console
compared to PC since there was an
auction house more gold available uh got
some some economists in in here
wondering about sort of how that's that
balance is on the console Visa versus
the PC well the Mystic uh if you have a
lot of gold um You Can Kiss It Goodbye
as soon as you get uh they start using
the Mystic because you will get addicted
to her and she charges a lot so uh yeah
just rrolling your really high-end items
is a pretty big goal Sy however at the
other end of the spectrum we tried to
make it much more friendly to the new
player so little things but like potions
are much less expensive for the new
player now all players really but new
players are the ones who really feel
that cost and uh uh just just trying to
make the game as friendly as
possible as friendly as possible well
that's why all those unicorns are in
there weide from all the stuff trying to
kill you it's as friendly as
possible all right I'm going to hop over
here to the Game Spot questions can
we uh yeah so folks are curious about
cross generation play PS3 to PS4
will people on PS3 be able to play with
PS4 people no you'll only be able to
play with people that are onl within the
same console console as you and that's
the case for other cross generation
games as
well Arc Taurus Oh I guess that question
got answered in the in the Gamespot
comments there's actually in the
comments on Gamespot there's a lot of
questions being asked that folks are
answering uh so thanks to you folks so
those knowledgeable folks sort of
engaging in the the dialogue there as
well as in the twitch chat we are coming
down to it here on our Diablo I ultimate
Evil Edition Q&A live stream so let me
just reiterate one more time that we are
giving some stuff away and this is the I
save the big thing to show off towards
the end it is the Lord Of Terror himself
ba boom look at this guy yeah 25 points
of articulation 25 points of
articulation and you must be 17 years or
older to use it 16 years old you're not
ready for this thing you just
yes what else you guys got you got some
good figurine factoids oh you just read
that off the front did our research here
I was Tiffany thinking you were some
kind of figure
Ace just reading the Box all right if
you want to win Diablo II The Lord Of
Terror or if you want to win two of
these cute pop vinyl dudes right here we
got Diablo interial or if you want to
win a
lanyard that looks like a sickle and
like oh there is it this guy
all you got to do is follow Gamespot on
Twitter and we'll be releasing we'll
beting information on how you can win
all that stuff once this stream is
concluded what how you guys going to
conclude the stream you're going to you
got to clear The Foundry bounty we have
one dud is really good at hiding smart
monster knows what's coming for it um
hun him down yeah like the doggy
is all right I'm going to try to grab a
few more questions here that we haven't
already
covered
uh I kit claw wondering are items for
your characters account bound if I get a
Helm I know my friend can use can I mail
it to him or you know is it just is the
sort of sharing just a gift specific no
you can mail you can mail any pretty
much anything in the game so if you know
your friend could use this item you can
use the mail system and send it right to
him sharing is caring after all yeah and
we also removed a lot of the trade
restrictions or pretty much all the
trade restrictions from PC because since
console is less of a global economy it's
they're much more Silo contained
economies we just really wanted to ear
on the side of just you being able to
help out your friends and and just be
cool to your
friends I like that
worldview I support it the Monkey Bongo
wants to know if you can play online
with people who are not on your friends
list if you can just get into a kind of
matchmaking situation you can so a big
draw of Dio is matchmaking on PC and we
support the same thing on ultimate Evil
Edition so you can choose what tags you
want whether you want to do campaign you
want to do Adventure Mode you want to do
bounties um what difficulty you want to
play in and you can matchmake over Xbox
Live or PlayStation Network also monkey
Bongos pretty awesome name it is a
pretty awesome name
yeah Monkey Bongo is getting the thumbs
up uh Marx are wondering if you've
already got Diablo I is there any way to
sort of upgrade to the ultimate Evil
Edition that's uh other than paying full
price for the new game well we really
wanted to make I mean couple things
first we just wanted to make it really
easy for people to get to the game so we
bundled it all into one little package
so we didn't want to make like a
traditional expansion where like hey
here's this box it doesn't do anything
unless you have this other box and oh
they might not have that box in the
store or uh also the other thing is a
lot since this is nextg there's this is
the first major RPG to come out on nextg
there a lot of new players with these
amazing consoles just waiting for
something really awesome to just dive
into we think you know this could be one
of the things they get really excited
about so we just want to make it super
easy One Stop Shop and uh as just
seamless as possible that's where it is
aggressively aggressive hammering was
was was a seamless friendliness get rid
of those seams
yes uh and did you sorry did you mention
any uh digital download versions of the
game is it going to be available so it
is available uh digitally it'll be
available digitally day one for
PlayStation 3 PlayStation 4 and Xbox One
and then on uh September 18th it'll be
available digitally for Xbox 360 as well
and so what's the first date that it's
available August 19th okay so August
19th that's the day you want to August
18th you want to go line up at
midnight 19th that's just under two
weeks away
or Diablo I ultimate Evil Edition comes
to PS4 PS3 Xbox One and Xbox 360 but you
also mentioned September 18th as a date
that it's going to be digitally
available for Xbox 360 Xbox 360 it'll be
available available digitally for the
other three platforms on August 19 on
launch day
yeah spy dude FX wondering about uh
previously earned trophies do you need
to rearn them or or is it just you've
got a whole new like you know through
the story or something like that is
there are they if if you've already
played through Diablo II on the console
you got some trophies under your belt do
you need to re earn them or do they or
can you re earn them we have a full new
set so you do re earn uh your
achievements and trophies regardless of
how far you got in the original Diablo 3
so there's a whole new set of challenges
for you yeah we just didn't think it'd
be fun like first thing you boot the
game is like unlocked unlocked unlocked
unlocked you know or just uh not having
the ability to re unlock
those all right folks we are almost done
here you guys going to it looks like
you've completed the Bounty yeah the act
one that we're
about two FS of the way through act
three we abandoned Captain hail oh did
we oh we have
honestly should learn to keep up that's
just it's kind of my
stance listen if you're not going to
keep up I'm sorry don't ask for
assistance yeah uh test the God on
Gamespot one is this is a question
that's been echoed a little bit earlier
if you've got you know if you join up
with people and maybe you're not you
know digging their play style you want
to keep continuing but you don't want
them to come along with you do you have
to quit out and sort of start another
game or can you can you bop people from
any games that you host or get into um
we decided to because PlayStation and uh
the Xbox support you know sort of
controlling who you play games with um
through just their individual systems we
decided to not complicate things and
have our own system so um you can handle
that through both the PlayStation and
Xbox menus themselves um you would have
to either leave the game or I'm not
exactly sure how kicking people works on
Xbox and Playstation I've never had to
do it myself but we're both pretty
friendly people I never had to do that
um it is supported through the consoles
themselves though so we don't have any
explicit in-game vote to kick features
or anything like that
cool all right
uh and deic 01 is wondering about event
type stuff I mean obviously on the PC
with having you know everybody connected
all the time can sort of do events that
people can participate in for a weekend
or something like that uh do you have
any plans for events on consoles in that
same kind of vein we do um we're still
looking to see exactly what events we
think would be supported best on the
console versions but that's definitely
something that we are keeping in
mind all
right oh my goodness those things are
nasty I think they're kind of cute love
them they you think they're kind of cute
kind of yeah do you guys sell plushies
of those we not not of him not yet I
wish that would be cool attach the
desk really awesome all right well
Tiffany Johnny thank you so much I think
we're going to wrap it up here Diablo I
ultimate Evil Edition coming out august
19 AUST a 19th anything else you guys
want to mention about the uh the whole
game situation before we wrap it up
we're just so excited to see it on nextg
I I don't know if you can tell but the
it's just jaw dropping and be gorgeous
this is how it was meant to be played
all right and if you guys have any
further questions uh go ahead and get
into the gam spot comments we've got
people answering questions there or you
can tweet at Tiffany maybe if I truck
her down on Twitter or TW tweet at me
and I'll send them that way Johnny stays
off the Twitter cuz we got to keep him
off Danger Zone Danger Zone Danger Zone
yes it is other B yeah remember we've
got uh stuff to give away including this
guy with over 25 points of articulation
according to Tiffany and the Box all you
got to do is follow Gamespot on Twitter
and we'll be giving away or we'll be
telling you how you can enter to win
that stuff thank you so much for
watching our Q&A live stream with
developers of Diablo I ultimate Evil
Edition Johnny Tiffany thank you again
for coming in and playing thanks for
having us all right folks that's a wrap
Diablo I ultimate Evil Edition coming
out in just two weeks